nos piden que encontremos el valor de
esta integral indefinida algunos de
ustedes al tratar de resolverla podrían
decir bueno si el numerador es la
derivada un múltiplo de la derivada del
denominador entonces podríamos usar un
cambio de variable pero aquí no es el
caso entonces que hacemos la pista que
puedo darte esta vez es que uses una
descomposición en fracciones parciales
que quizás invocar a los recuerdos de
las clases de pre cálculo o de álgebra 2
esta es una técnica que separa esta
expresión racional en la suma de dos
expresiones racionales aquí una buena
pista es el hecho de que este
denominador se puede actualizar en estas
dos expresiones entonces lo que
intentaremos hacer en una descomposición
de fracciones parciales es tratar de
escribir x 5 entre 2 x menos 3 por x
menos 1 como la suma de dos expresiones
es donde el denominador de la primera
será 2x menos 3 y el denominador de la
segunda será x menos 1 ahora no
conocemos los numeradores por lo tanto
te animo a que si esta es la primera vez
que ves descomposición en fracciones
parciales veas el tema en khan academy
tenemos varios vídeos sobre el tema el
principio general es que los numeradores
tendrán un grado menos que el grado que
tiene el denominador entonces si
nuestros denominadores tienen grado 1
nuestros numeradores deben tener grados
0 es decir serán constantes entonces
tendremos una cierta constante
desconocida que llamaremos am en la
primera expresión y otra constante ve
también desconocida para la segunda
expresión y nuestro objetivo es
encontrar a y ver todo esto es un repaso
esto no es cálculo es mas precálculo o
álgebra como podemos encontrar a ive
bueno vamos a sumar las como si
estuviéramos sumando dos fracciones con
denominadores distintos por lo tanto si
queremos tener un denominador común lo
que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar
esta primera expresión racional por x
menos 1 en el denominador y en el
numerador entonces obtendremos a que
multiplican a x menos 1 entre 2 x menos
3 por x menos 1 y ahora para esta
segunda expresión racional lo que vamos
a hacer será multiplicar el numerador y
el denominador por 2 x menos 3 2 x menos
3 que va a multiplicar ab entre 2 x
menos 3 por x menos 1 ahora como ya
tenemos el mismo denominador podemos
sumar las el objetivo es que al sumarlas
y pensar en el numerador intentemos
alinear estas as ibex con lo que
teníamos en un principio por lo tanto
esto será igual am tenemos el mismo
denominador 2 x menos 3 por ex menos 1
y en el numerador tendremos primero
déjenme describir esto esto es lo mismo
que a x menos
am si distribuimos la am y distribuimos
la vez en la segunda expresión
tenemos dos veces por x menos 3 b por lo
tanto si sumamos los numeradores primero
sumaremos los términos x que tengo es
decir a x + 2 b x que es lo mismo que a
más 2 b por x y si sumamos los términos
constantes
tengo menos a menos 3 b pero como
tenemos un signo menos acá arriba voy a
tratar de emparejar lo más que pueda
entonces me quedarán menos que
multiplican
3b observa que se distribuye este signo
negativo obtendrás menos al menos tres
veces por lo tanto esto es equivalente y
ahora podemos ver el patrón observa
nuestros denominadores son los mismos
por lo tanto este numerador debe de ser
igual a x menos 5
dicho de otra manera sea cual sea el
coeficiente de x aquí este tiene que ser
igual a 1 ya que es el coeficiente de x
al inicio y eso que estamos restando
debe de ser igual a 5 y con esto
establecemos un sistema de dos
ecuaciones con dos incógnitas para
encontrar a y b déjame notar las sabemos
que a más 2 b esto debe de ser igual a 1
y que a más 3 b debe de ser igual a 5
ahora encontremos a ibm y podemos
hacerlo por eliminación
qué pasa si multiplicamos la ecuación de
arriba por menos 1 obtenemos menos a
menos 2 b y menos 1 y ahora podemos
sumar las el punto era cancelar a y nos
queda menos 2 b 3 b eso simplemente
vemos que es igual a 4 y con esto
podemos sustituir este valor para
obtener a tenemos que a
+ 3 x 4 será 12 ojo estoy usando esta
segunda ecuación esto es igual a 5
ahora si restamos 12 de ambos lados
obtenemos que a es igual a menos 7 ya
con esto podemos reescribir esta
integral completa podemos decir que esto
es igual a la integral indefinida de y
abrimos paréntesis a entre 2 x menos 3
pero sabemos que a es igual a menos 7
entonces tengo menos 7 entre 2 x menos 3
ya esto le sumaremos pp pero como
sabemos que ver es igual a 4 entonces
tengo 4 / x menos 1 cerramos el
paréntesis y escribimos de x
ahora bien si te sientes inspirado te
animo a que pausa el vídeo e intentes
encontrar la respuesta desde este punto
porque ya hemos visto las técnicas para
resolver este tipo de integrales pero de
todas formas lo haremos juntos paso por
paso esto será lo mismo que la integral
de m bueno como denominador tengo 2x
menos 3 y puedo poner el menos 7 en el
numerador pero mejor lo sacaré de la
integral ya que es una constante
entonces tendremos menos 7 al inicio y
arriba me quedara un 1 sin embargo
estaría muy bien si arriba tuviéramos un
2 porque porque todos es la derivada del
denominador de 2x menos 3 de modo que
con esto podemos hacer nuestro cambio de
variable que hemos practicado varias
veces entonces si queremos un 2 aquí no
podemos simplemente multiplicar por 2
también tenemos que dividir entre 2 y
eso lo hacemos afuera porque eso es una
constante
x más ahora la derivada de x menos 1 es
simplemente 1 entonces necesitamos un 1
en el numerador así que podemos sacar el
4 de la integral y nos queda 4 por la
integral de 1 / x menos 1 de x y esto
será igual a poniendo primero nuestra
constante a fuera menos siete medios y
como tenemos esta expresión en el
denominador y su derivada arriba podemos
pensar que estamos integrando con
respecto a la expresión del denominador
puedes ver el cambio de variable como la
inversa de la regla de la cadena pero no
lo vamos a hacer aquí de una manera
explícita
sabemos que el anti derivada de uno
entre x de x es el logaritmo natural del
valor absoluto de x pero aquí la anti
derivada de esto va a ser el logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de 2x menos 3
y para la segunda parte tenemos más 4
por la anti derivada de s
qué es el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de x menos 1 una vez más puedo
hacer esto ya que la derivada de x menos
1 es simplemente 1 y por supuesto si
estamos tomando una integral definida no
debemos olvidar sumar nuestra sep
al final y ya con esto hemos terminado
así que seguiremos en los vídeos futuros